oui steve jobs alimenté comment tu te
sens mieux et c'est très très content je
sais pas je le rends pas compte
c'est très décevant et un mec derrière
toi et tes les carreaux c'est un
week-end non moi je suis content bravo
paul si je suis très contente et c'est
ça qu'on aime qu'on a deux fois par
semaine ça va tout est content il à poil
le mec pareil je te jure qu'il avait
mais non tu regardes autour de toi
ce qui l'est c'est une blague mais qu'il
a monté d'un coup il était à poil
varennes
mais t'es con tu crois pas mais c'est
toi qui mois d'octobre par donc une
touche féminine gamera là mais tu es
malade ou quoi mais n'en avaient filmé
mais tu as vraiment vu en mettant la
médiation afin qu'un poil mais il y
avait des jambes écartées et tout
s'arrangera pour lui aussi
[Musique]
[Rires]
la médecine est très bien sur quoi à son
âge qui sont les faits je sais que je
peux faire ça c'est pas un problème
et qu'est-ce que je peux faire avec toi
écoute est-ce que tu as besoin des
chroniqueurs je sais pas si je suis la
bonne personne je ne sais pas si on a
toujours besoin mais c'est normal
le monsieur qui monsieur derrière toi et
le monsieur il avait toutes ces paradis
les rangs je ne me souviens pas en avant
ce n'était pas un juge alors qu'il avait
la peau ah oui les départements cités je
suis persuadé qu'il est la dernière
femme comme qui le monsieur il est marié
avec l'arrêt quoi j'assimile nationale
et l'ipod touch wiki excessivement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
petit vois pas qui est à l'enjeu
vous allez bien madame mais il est où
ton talent déjà vaudront plus là non tu
n'es pas content mais tu le sais pas
mais je me suis excusé moi j'avais un
gros seins et c'est si on n'est pas leur
parler les cinq ans
[Musique]
la france
je vais trouver style parce que
ouais je suis très contente toi tu avais
mon sens je suis avec toi ce soir tu
avais beaucoup maintenant derrière sa
mêlée car moi je me sens vraiment chez
moi j'ai ouais je sais que c'est grâce à
mary je les remercie aussi je pourrais
me dis attention parce que eric il a
quand même c'était tu vas des gens qui
l'aiment bien d'autres
sans déconner kit home et imac est
[Musique]
exceptionnel c'est magnifique l'abordage
si je pars c'est pour ça
[Applaudissements]